I just was listening all the stuff you
do you've got these multiple TV shows
yeah that you're working on got the
podcast which is destroying it you are I
mean most importantly I have this
incredible movie coming out for now tell
us about the movie well I want to but
generally I come here and I'll talk up a
movie and then some people show a clip
and people like yeah a lot of bark no
bite right right that you've got here
several Pinker's come through the pipe
sure yeah sure we all do not everybody
okay some people but this one is so
incredible I would I'd actually like to
show a clip first so that you can see
how great it is and then we can talk
you're that excited about mice I know I
can bet on this I can bet on it
okay all right let's take a look what do
you say sure let's do it I guess you're
supposed to saying okay let's let's
let's take a look at this this is taxes
new film this is greatest mistake of
your life we didn't even kiss you oh we
all kind of got it okay all off you're
up okay so much easier now that I can
read lightning round
boys against girls I'm ready I'm ready
go
unicorn ice-cream castle oaken teapot
maps Oh Elsa
I don't think Olaf should get to
rearrange
ah you're not in frozen - not
technically but Kristen and I were
married in California which is a
community property state which means
anything she acquires during our
marriage is half mine so we have the
exact same stake in frozen - you're
promoting frozen - because your your
wife is in it and I own half of
everything I just thought it'd be rude
to not get out and at least try to sell
with me yeah yeah yeah I wanted to ring
that bell in the clip they wouldn't
allow me to but I can tell you she had a
really good time on the film
she loves the crew and the drawers or
whatever three years to make which I
don't understand yeah yeah but I know
how to spend that money when it comes
what oh yes oh oh yeah let me tell you
about her okay
incredible when she sings it's like a
Bruce Lee fight scene the song just
builds and builds and builds and then
just that knock out note she hits and
I'm not saying that I had anything to do
with that but I'll be very involved
again with spending so you're gonna
watch frozen - very differently than
anyone else that's right you're gonna
watch it thinking about the money that's
coming to you through marriage in this
movie that's yes largely yes how you
produced it all it truly is great it's
really really good I had seen I can say
this they Godfather to it it's better
than the first one
really yeah that's saying a lot no and
not a trim anyone would say today but
maybe in the mid 70s here's a question
yeah here's a question when you saw and
be honest when you saw the first frozen
you went with your wife and you saw it
in a screening before it was released
yeah did you predict that it was gonna
become one of the biggest animated hits
of all time and then a franchise did you
think that was gonna happen
no I don't know anything about what
makes a good cartoon I was like oh
that's good singing everyone was
really on pitch I guess is that even
this is you this is you watching it you
were just sitting there going I don't
know I didn't know I didn't know but my
wife knew she knew she liked them the
movie ended and she looked at me like oh
my god it happened I'm in one of these
yeah but I I was out to lunch on it but
now this time we saw it three weeks ago
for the first time and and no one had
seen it so as all the actors in the
movie and the producers and the writers
and everything and I said before the
movie started I said hey if you see me
on my phone in the middle of the film
I'm not bored I just think we got it and
I'm shopping for yachts the very best
yachts are so those are the good yachts
out there I said conversely if I'm on my
phone like two-thirds of the way through
and I'm selling things on Craigslist I
think it's a stinker liquidating so when
you're on the phone yeah so the movie
ended in the director really said in the
screen he said acts how did we do and I
said I bought a beautiful 52-foot son
see you're confident yeah it's really
really terrific and my wife's she's I
don't know she is so funny she's funnier
than us she's she's more creative she
can sing like the best of them it's it's
mind-blowing how how talented she is I
cry when she sees also yeah let's go
let's get the word out on Kristen Bell
help it get out now how is your career
we've taught you've talked at great
length music you've used most of your
segments to discuss Kristin Kristin
Kristin Kristin and frozen how do you
feel you're doing I mean I said you got
the pocket you got a lot of things going
but how are you feeling about it all
well the thing is is none of those
things pay as well as frozen to so I
have to do way more things to try to
match her that's right you do a lot and
that's why you're doing it is she can do
one frozen and get this and you have to
do 300 TV shows yeah I'm I have a game
show I'm on two sitcoms I have that
podcast yeah I'm also I shoot bless this
mess in Santa Clarita and I'm grabbing
folks uber making 40 bucks on the way
home and I try to tell her that's cash
money there's no agent there's no lawyer
that's straight in our pocket yeah now
still doesn't add up
doesn't add up